yeah I'm struggling it's a timed hey
everything is hard now I got Cayenne on
my hand even though in 14 I have been
cooking since I was 5 but I've really
been taking it seriously since I was 11
I have a little cooking experience I can
cook a decent meal I cook at home three
to four times a week so I got that
experience
homemade hollandaise sauce prosciutto
arugula Eggs Benedict chef Clark is the
best chef in the world
Libby I've never faced off against an
adult look I see things I'm an adult how
old do you think I am I'm gonna go over
35 so the timeline is 30 minutes
definitely enough time to take down a
little kids ego it's been a while since
I had a time competition but I'm feeling
confident feel like I can beat him how
do you get your butt beat yep let's go
dude good luck yeah
Owen good luck buddy cuz you're gonna
need it I guess I'll take this cream I
can do some kind of sauce with that
I need this parsley I feel like I really
have to use my creativity here like pull
something together you know sort through
this fridge and find what I want to use
yeah I think this is it I got the
chicken for my protein I might take the
skin and make like skin and crisps wilt
this spinach
glazed it with some of the chicken stock
and make tomato concassé with this
[Music]
okay this is a lot more stocks than I
thought I'm seeing these beautiful
peppers pop out of me I'm seeing
jalapenos I'm seeing chicken I'm from
Texas love tex-mex already my mind's
going we could do like a deconstructed
chicken fajita it sounds fancy if you
say things we deconstructed right I
think I'm gonna destroy the competition
everyone's gonna love my tacos you know
we talk about taco wing about it all day
I don't really know how much cooking
experience Clark has you might have not
a lot but still be really amazing at
cooking I feel like I could finish early
Oh mr. confident over here a the
tortoise wins a race I'm gonna win is
what I'm trying to say where's just
olive oil dude sesame oil if you want to
do high heat cooking ideas this one what
help me what Thanks I'm supposed to be
like clobbering you right now and you're
helping me out and kind of get a nice
little coating of a taco seasoning on my
chickens thought you were making your
own taco seasoning I saw this hey if you
got a premix why not
is it working so I just started cooking
and I realized I didn't know how it
still worked and now I'm stressing I'm
like oh crap this is gonna be a lot
harder than I thought what is five six
seven that's the heat like is it like
the level yeah cool great why are you
helping me again Clark doesn't know how
to use induction cooktop I feel like it
could be an advantage for me if he
doesn't know how to turn on his stove he
can't cook anything can't forget my
favorite ingredient the Cayenne I'm
watching Clark cook and then he takes
Kai in uh I don't know if he knows how
spicy Cayenne is or not but he just
takes it turns it upside down yeah all
right so I like my stuff spicy sir gonna
get a nice big Cayenne on there
a lot comes out he's just like oh yeah
it's fine I like spicy food no that's
it's like blow your head off I'm trying
something new usually beurre Blanc's
made with white wine I'm making it with
beer and I have no clue how this is
gonna turn out did you just say beer
yeah are you even old enough to buy beer
know what this is not legal
do you have some for me over there it's
gonna get a nice little coating on the
skin get it nice and crispy
I cut myself that was a minor setback
here you came in yeah I'm fine is it a
bad cut no it's
just that okay so since I cut my finger
I had to use a glove it was a tiny
setback in time so the version of this
dish that I'm making is actually my
parents recipe they call it Mexican
Stephanie it's a super easy dish I mean
it's just rice protein and then whatever
toppings you want I mean there's only so
much you can do with like a chicken
fajita I could go crazy and like
crumpled up like Doritos on there I'm
gonna Drita's Jordans do we have any
Doritos no we're out of jury toes so now
I'm gonna keep it just playing a simple
Mexican stack
knife skills are questionable
look at these sad old jalapenos from the
BuzzFeed refrigerator they've been
sitting in a hot tub for like three
years and just burned all up oh this is
a fun game
let's see old bands I love that you may
not know do you know blink 182 nope
Taking Back Sunday no no thirty Seconds
to Mars
no Backstreet Boys they're the ones that
always wore the white suits right yeah
our music tapes are really different you
know I don't know any of these bands
he's talking about but often like 20
years ago or something just cook tell me
some bands and I'll see if I know or do
you know a little pump is little pump
yeah is a musical pump I got this kidney
peppers onions taco seasoning everything
is coming along nicely this the pops of
color my face is on fire cuz I touched
it with cayenne the life is good
[Music]
oh man I made it too spicy there's one
thing you could do
oh it is like well a piano it spicy you
can add tomato puree to it oh my good
what are you helping me Eric you don't
matter this is too spicy there's five
minutes left you know I have everything
together my chickens resting my sauce is
done all I have to do now is play and
you know I have plenty of time too so
I'm not flustered at all are you
struggling over there I just tasted my
pico de gallo and it is great
no struggles over here you have anything
uh finished that you can taste yet I'll
even know you're cooking it don't look
good
[Music]
what are you doin over here lady oh we
got two minutes oh crap that's too much
[Music]
why guy is good is it cooked well you
don't know so yeah thanks that was good
it's spicy but like it's not a blow your
head off but yeah take a look at that
baby
look at my food well it didn't taste
like it was cooked by your forcing your
old boy like it tasted like a top chef
junior winter cooked it where'd you
learn to cook
there's not Culinary Institute of
artists mine is this stuff you get it
like a mom-and-pop Mexican restaurant
like yours is like the fancy Italian
restaurant you go to I would have like
oh you got a nice like crispy skin
[Music]
so the chicken is actually like
perfectly cooked but it's very very
aggressively seasoned it kind of hurts
my mouth and my back of the throat a
little bit I think the ingredients go
together really well and I can get like
just a hint of flavor and each
ingredient here chicken is not dry it's
pretty spicy though so the chicken is
also perfectly cooked on this one I
really like the sauce here too very rich
chicken is cooked really well
just enough seasoning my favorite dish
my favorite out of the two my favorite
out of the two dishes is number two dish
two number two and it's because of the
sauce it's super bright and it's super
nice and it makes the whole thing taste
so much better I think the flavors go
really well together I really really
like the texture of the crispy skin
everything like worked really well
together
no ingredient was overpowering the other
it was very rich a lot more the winner
of this sandwich our versus pro
you know feels good to be an adult feels
good to be somebody who's 13 years older
than you good job dude thank you we need
to do the trophy but on something in my
room there we go not even grateful bring
[Music]